the Lakers got some free throws early
they haven't been able to get to the
line and after this next one by wittings
both teams will have shot 12 free throws
after a huge advantage in the first
three games for the Lakers
[Music]
a reminder that the NBA on TNT is
brought to you by Clorox we are
unstoppable when we start clean
[Applause]
James will sit and won't be Outlaw now
tamura comes in and Andrew Wiggins
knocks down both free throws
[Music]
James is already going back to the
scores table
somehow I'll finish
[Music]
LeBron James is right back on the floor
I thought he got plenty of rest there I
think he's coming back in refreshed
right now Brian never sat down
yeah but he got to walk over to the
sideline I mean he he stood there for I
don't know 20 seconds he should be good
he and Davis are both going to end up
playing 43 minutes in this game yeah
they're at 37 right now Reeves scared of
by Moody Austin Reeves pitch shot
makes it a two-point game 19 points for
Austin Reed